The biggest enemy is ourselves.
We need to fight no learning,
special professional.
Majority of everybody get a lot of
injuries in the past.
You need to fight with them every day.
You know you need.
We're continuing to show you're a
stretch and do your best.
You need to balance everything too fast.
There is no good,
but it's too slow.
It's also not good.
You need a balance,
so that's.
I like martial art.
I always tell you how to control your
body,
your mind,
your heart,
the balance balance can keep the world
peace.
I always tell myself,
forgot to press what I do,
what I did in the past.
I haven't met the new guy today.
I read there is new things happen.
I need to learn English.
I need to learn things.
Learn American style because older,
older,
but at you need still need a study
study,
study.
It just becomes happier.
To do.
You really wanted to know for the just a
name where money,
you need to do something you really want
to do.
I do know the future,
but if I really wanted to do,
I start.
I do my best today from Jvs had is do
your best at everything every day in
everyday training.
Work,
everything.
Just good enough.